romain rom apophyses je crois que jamais
un fils maïs amer autant que moi à ce
moment-là général
un bateau et je dois ce rire ce que je
suis j'étais résolu à devenir tout ce
qu'elle attendait de moi
non non pas par bongo qui s'est suicidé
à 35 ans je veux que tu sois célèbre de
temps bouillon
nous résignons à la littérature
trois raisons qu'ils méritent tu te
battre
des femmes en or et la france et sera
clos
tu veux pas me [ __ ] un peu la paix et
t'occuper de ta fille
[Musique]
l'idée que ma mère pu mourir avant que
j'ai accompli tout ce qu'elle attendait
de moi mais tu est intolérable
alex devienne un génie de la littérature
française en écrivant un chef-d'oeuvre
immortel
[Musique]
je me fit la promesse de donner un fond
sacrifices
ziegler
allait consacrer ma vie
c'est à jour
ça fait des mois que tu n'as rien écrit
ça veut rien dire sans dire qu'à la
guerre ça veut dire que je peux pas
faire autre chose que je fais ce que tu
m'as demandé
alors je promis à tout le monde ce qui
allait sauver la france
la victoire
et je t'interdis de mourir
il
et sans doute n'est-il pas permis
d'aimer un seul être à ce point fut-il
votre mère
[Musique]